[Music]
our following guest is one of the great
quarterbacks in Notre Dame history he's
also one of the quarterbacks in Brown's
history his hair is better than yours
every one of you his abs have abs having
him and Tom Brady both at Fox might put
them over the handsomeness cap two
minutes before this interview he was
doing a party pump in The Green Room
everybody's sucking your gut and please
welcome Brady Quinn yeah
thank you for that also part of uh the
big noon kickoff with uh Fox Sports and
two pros and a cup of joe the radio show
right before us and uh Brady Quinn is in
the house how was that intro there uh
that was unique that was one of the
first I think anytime you're mentioned
the same context as Tom Brady it's
usually a good thing okay although I
haven't posed to my boxers recently so
I'm not going to at any point I saw that
where did Tom lose a bet where he had to
pose in his boxers I mean that's one way
of looking at it I mean he is single
yeah but it feels like he's trying to
move product here like you you haven't
feel like it was kind of a dual purpose
there right like maybe it's it's moving
products a little catchy right creates
some waves but at the same time it's
like hey I still look pretty good
uh is there a rift between you and Brady
now that you know he's coming to Fox uh
no okay I've I've you know I I was
fortunate enough to grow up in an era
where I idolized him in in high school
in kind of those formative Years playing
quarterback and then I get to Notre Dame
and at that point in time when I went to
play for Ty Willingham
you know you're paying attention to his
career but you're not watching it as
closely when you get his former
offensive coordinator to be my Head
Coach Charlie Weiss and so for the next
two years of my life I really I watched
more film on him than I did myself in
practice because I was trying to mimic
everything that he was doing and how he
ran the offense in New England and how
Charlie one of the offense running Notre
Dame so I've always had the utmost
respect for him the way he's managed
himself his career and and probably just
because I'm like one of those Meatheads
who loved working out
he his sacrifice in the offseason and
what he did when no one else was
watching and how he prepared his body to
be able to play until he's 45. I think
that's one of the things that stands out
the most like we can talk about
accolades and his Poise and composure
and you know certain points in Super
Bowls but it's the sacrifice that he was
willing to make that no one else was
willing to make over the course of their
entire lifespan playing in the NFL but
there have been so many more talented
quarterbacks but arm strength speed
everything
but why Tom Brady I don't think you can
measure what's inside him right whether
it's his heart whether that's that chip
on his shoulder you know I kind of
related it to
um you know seeing the Jordan document
which everyone watched obviously over
the course of the pandemic and then and
you remember some of the stories like oh
the flu game and all this other stuff
and you're like wait a second he was
just making this all up to motivate
himself and it's like somewhere in the
back of Tom Brady's mind he remembers
that he was still a six round Pig and he
was the second pick if I'm not mistaken
the New England Patriots in that draft
and I think he would carry it with him
wherever he went I think he'd carry it
with him that people would say what you
just said that he's not the most
talented or he's not this or he's not
that and meanwhile it still has allowed
him to be the most successful and the
greatest of all time in my opinion do
you think he was addicted to football
yeah I think it's pretty cool too you
know I always I got I got three little
girls and I'm like praying and waiting
for the moment where they start to be
like addicted to a sport and something
that's like healthy and awesome for them
that they can learn from and uh I think
my oldest daughter Sloan starting to get
there now with soccer like they they
lost the other day then lost in seven
games they're 7-1 they're crushing it's
an all girls team playing against a
bunch of boys teams and all that and so
they're doing great but they lost and
she looked at me she's like Dad I want
to go home and practice and I was like
that's awesome and she and she kept
wanting to practice and practice and
finally I was like okay I want to go
inside and do something else so but you
don't think it could be detrimental that
Brady couldn't he couldn't walk away
from it no and I think we've publicly
seen some of the sacrifices that he's
had to make and that's just that's a
choice that we all have to make though
with our own lives right I mean we all
make but how common do you think this is
oh incredibly uncommon I mean again it
goes back to the sacrifice he made in
the off season prepare his body and all
that and the sacrifices that he made
personally and even professionally to
some degree too with I think how he even
manages his own brand whereas now he I
mean he is the brand right it's the
Brady brand he's got his name on it and
he's got a posing boxers and without a
close on it and also you know people say
well Tom you know he'll be an announcer
Troy says just be yourself elf and it's
not that easy and Albert Brier from the
Monday Morning Quarterback said you know
Tom has maybe compromised himself
because he is friends with people is he
going to be critical of those people how
honest can you be you know when you make
that transition where now all of a
sudden they go you got an opinion on
somebody yeah and then that person hears
what your opinion is and then you're
like well I'm sorry I oh I was I was
already getting into this year I mean
Jets fans obviously were saying some
stuff about it and I'd been there for
half a season and I had a buddy of the
Giants who was give me some Flack about
it which is funny because I mean I root
for all those guys you know people
who've been around that work in the
industry you root for them but at the
same time people are obviously asking
you for for betting advice as part of
your job as an analyst now that's become
so much more part of what we're asked to
do and and you have to be real with what
you think is going to happen now you're
not gonna be right but you know that's
part of the job part of what comes with
it I think it's harder for oh I'll put
it this way if anyone could be critical
I'm pretty sure it's Tom Brady like I
I'm pretty sure he can
it might not be in him and it might not
be who he is but I I guess what's what's
easier for him is to be like well I'm
the greatest of all time so if I say
that like this guy should have done this
I think most people are gonna be like oh
yeah it's Tom Brady like if it's Brady
Quinn's saying it they're like that guy
didn't make it like he's a joke get out
of here you know so so it's like two
completely different inspections like
it's harder for me to be critical I
think in part because like I know how
hard it is and now he he knows how hard
it is too but the difference is like
there's certain things that came pretty
easy to Tom Brady so when he sees bad
football he's probably going to
acknowledge bad football I came in a
couple of uh Mondays after watching
Mahomes play on Saturday and you know
Texas Tech wasn't a great football team
and they were always you know in a
shootout because it was Big 12 Football
I didn't know if he could play in the
NFL at a high level I just thought it
was fascinating to watch somebody play
the position and plus it's Texas Tech
quarterbacks so you're thinking are
there everybody puts up big numbers
right but he had this innate ability to
almost have a calmness and a he
freelanced it felt like back there he
was running a pro offense or his offense
when he was at Texas Tech but I didn't
know that would translate to this what
did you think and there were a lot of
doubters about him that maybe he was a
gunslinger and trying to be Brett Favre
like yeah I always go back to the the
matchup between Oklahoma with Baker
Mayfield and Patch my Holmes there and
love it we got to call that match up and
and Joe Davis was doing play-by-play and
at one point we looked at each on the
booth we're like we're gonna have to
change our flights like that everyone
kept scoring back and forth so much like
we're never going to go home at this
point
um but it was one of those moments where
I kind of I thought to myself
what's going to happen is people are
going to overlook in their evaluation
the fact that
um he's doing things that he's literally
carrying this team their defense was was
very bad during the course of time he
was there at Texas Tech and people are
going to knock him and say oh he wasn't
a winner that's like can we just pump
the brakes on that and then look what he
was dealing with every single game when
you have to put up 40 50 points in order
to win uh it was a heavy burden to carry
and I think what people sometimes
Overlook is they're like well you can't
play like that in the NFL well yeah you
can if you have his skill set and if you
have the right situation circumstance
which he does in Kansas City you know
Playmakers uh one of the greatest head
coaches of all time and Andy Reed who
can put him in those positions to
succeed
um and so if he went to the Bears it'd
be a much more difficult climb okay I
mean I think you can make that case with
any quarterback we opened up talking
about Tom Brady if he's not with Bill
Belichick to start how does his career
look different
um and I think that's where you know we
we praise quarterbacks so much for what
they do but it's still the ultimate team
sport and the coaches that are involved
in the front office everyone who makes
it possible they still play a much
bigger role than I think anyone on the
outside realizes
how do you explain you know the the
draft is loaded with these players but
especially a quarterback where you go
that guy made it and that guy didn't
yeah Jalen hurts
lost his job now he's a maybe we thought
he was just going to be a a backup or a
curiosity and then all of a sudden first
playoff game didn't look that good and
now here he is and uh you know an MVP
candidate it just goes back to what's on
the inside you know I think Jalen hurts
is the type of young man that from his
time at Alabama to Oklahoma to Philly
every single year he's continued to get
better and better and grow from that I
think one of the tough things is when
everyone's doubting you is to keep your
confidence in yourself and your
abilities and there's some guys who are
better doing that than others and I
think Jalen's an example of someone
who's done a much better job of
believing in himself believing in what
he's capable of but also finding that
right situation of circumstance I mean
let's not kid ourselves with 17 players
or either starters or Pro Bowl
alternates in the Pro Bowl or whatever
the heck that is nowadays
um but it goes to show you how talented
this team is and so when you're on a
talented team like that you're not
pressed to do quite the same things that
Joe burrow was asked to do when he first
got the Cincy and then as they've built
out around them I mean his job's gotten
a little easier there's still a lot of
heavy carrying there though can the
Eagles win a shooter yeah I think I
think they can and because I think
they're to me I'd look at it two ways I
don't know that it's gonna be a shootout
because I think they're so dominant on
both sides of the ball you know when you
look at the depth they have defensively
obviously everyone's gonna talk about
the pressure in sacks but they've also
improved in the rush defense and there's
some missed tackles and you can see that
in the NFC championship game but
um when they brought in linval Joseph
and Ndamukong Suh they started to shore
up some of that and those guys are
experienced guys who've been there
before so you like the eagles
um you know what this game feels like
this game feels similar to and I know
the Dynamics are different on offense
for the Chiefs where their offensive
line was banged up when they faced Tampa
but you saw patrimo homes were running
around for his his life and the Chiefs
are much improved on their offensive
line in this matchup but
Mahomes is still hamper with the ankle I
don't know how close they'll be to 100
you know he moved around pretty well
despite that in the AFC Championship
game but that's my concern is you've got
a group a defensive front that I don't
think you can you can't give too much
help to to one side or another and I
think they match up pretty well too in
the secondary
so that affords Jonathan Gannon the
opportunity to either get pressure with
four or bring pressure from time to time
and that's where if Mahomes isn't as
mobile he could begin a lot of hits on
him with that with that front I just
think they're that dominant the way they
play this year talking to Brady Quinn
from uh Fox Sports also the big noon
kickoff on Fox then you have Zach Wilson
and he was the one guy I thought if
there's a bust it was going to be him
because he was a one-year starter and I
don't even know if he was scheduled to
start you know his final year in college
but he goes to the Jets and you know
there's that
I don't know what you bring in when
you're that you know picked high like do
you have to walk in as I'm hey I'm the
guy yeah or do you have to walk in and
say you know how do we become successful
it almost felt like it was an i versus
we when he got there but how do you
explain somebody who had that talent but
is probably going to be a backup uh you
know in the near future I always said
this just in evaluating him in that
draft class in particular because the
covet year their schedule has changed
they played basically a group of five
schedule and probably his most difficult
game that final year was the Coastal
Carolina game they're a good team that
year we all got to see
um you know that group and Grace McCall
and all those all those players but they
brought more pressure on him he
struggled and when you go back through
the previous years watching him play I
never really saw a player that was ready
to be interjected to start playing right
now and when you're drafted number two
overall that's what the team's telling
you is you're going to play your rookie
year you're probably going to play right
away or at least you should so I think
anyone who is a Jets fan or even anyone
in the front office who thought was
going to come in right away and be able
to Showcase his arm Talent or some of
his mobility and that skill set they had
to have all the pieces around him the
rookie year they didn't have it now
they've continued to build on that
roster I think when the offensive line
is healthy when Breece Hall is healthy
with Garrett Wilson and wide receiver
and the rest of the wide receiving core
that's a very talented roster now it's
just a matter of you know him being to
the spot where he can manage all of that
and operate their system the issue is
you're now on a different offensive
coordinator Nathaniel Hackett you know
jumps in that spot
I personally you know what and I said I
just look I was I didn't have them as
high ranked as other people did for that
draft class but I also hated the way
Robert Saul handled this year you know
if you're going to you need to find out
what you're having them you need to let
him work through that adversity you made
the draft pick so own up to it and even
though if you're worried about losing
the locker room that's on Zach to figure
out that's not on you you know you got a
plan you gotta you gotta you know force
him to go through those growing planes
depends and see if he can't come out on
the other you know other side stronger
and better from it and then that way you
have a much better idea of where he's at
you know I think this year with the way
they handled the situation I think it's
more of a question mark than it would
have been had they just let him play
through the season at least after two
years we would have said okay we kind of
know where we're at now with them yeah
it reminds me of the Yankees when they
had Jabba Chamberlain whenever he got
into trouble they'd pull him out of a
game and he never got to pitch out of
adversity and that's where you find out
who you are and what you're all about is
hey I mean Tom Brady's down 28-3 if he
didn't have moments before that he'd get
to 28-3 and go oh I'm going to get
embarrassed here they're going to call
me over written like he was like no one
play at a time one touchdown you know
all of those things that your coaches
you know teach you we're talking to
Brady Quinn these quarterbacks coming
out now you do so much homework on
college football the one guy that can't
miss at the quarterbacking position yeah
thanks yeah I mean we're know it all
years after that you know I told you
Zach Wilson and we're not taping this so
don't even worry about it whatever you
say brady I I would say this
um based on watching his tape and
knowing everything about him it's it's
to me it's Bryce young now everyone's
going to question you about his his size
his height his weight all that is he
durable enough will he be durable enough
I I can't answer that I mean the team
that he gets drafted to and how they
protect him and how they put things
around them that'll probably more you
know Define what happens the rest of the
way but
um he is such a unique talent in the way
he's able to navigate the pocket keep
his eyes down field shape throws but
throw awkwardly too I mean just the way
he's able to put ball the ball in spots
whether it's a short intermediate
downfield and he's got enough arm
strength you know he's not as strong as
will Levis it's not as strong as Anthony
Richardson but he's the one that if I
was a team drafting I would take him
number one overall even before he
started I was a neighbor just watching
this first spring game and then and
watching him play and how he plays the
game he just has he kind of has a Steph
Curry feel to him where you look at him
and if you focus too much on the fact is
not you know the biggest you know almost
athletic guy you're going to miss some
of the special skill that he has
well I think Anthony Richard we we love
potential oh yeah and Anthony I had a
scout tell me early in the year he's
like Ben Roethlisberger and I go
okay he's way more Dynamic Dante
Culpepper he's more Dynamic than Dante
um I would say and she he's first first
15 picks his top mentality he's got the
highest ceiling of anyone I mean that
young man when you put on the tape and
you see him play well you just go oh if
he can just put this together
consistently that's something special I
mean even at times like the Tennessee
game in particular you see times when he
kind of navigates the POG with his feet
snaps his feet around makes it accurate
Kaepernick no because I think his motion
is more refined and more fluid
Kaepernick seemed raw it seemed like he
had his baseball background and you
could see that in his throwing motion
and his mechanics are you in love
um I'm not going that I say I'm more in
love with Bryce young like I I gush over
Bryce young at times you know he's just
he I I texted leinert this I think it
was earlier this year and I just said to
him I go like I enjoy watching Bryce
Young play like there's just something
about the way he plays the game with
Richardson you can just see the
potential and you can see what he can
become but we all get caught up in this
whole hey who's the next Josh Allen and
that's all like there's only one Josh
Allen now there's a will Levis there's
Anthony Richton guys who've showcased
the ability where you see that top end
but at times you also see the floor and
you're like all right well the NFL is
about like trying to limit how much you
play at your floor but to seeing how
close you can get to playing at that
ceiling as much as you can
within your skill set and so both will
Levis and Anthony Richardson I think our
first round talents if you're based on
their upside but at times you're going
to watch their tape and go all right I
can see why if they slid that's probably
why teams are concerned concerned about
the lack of ability to develop them
because no one develops quarterbacks now
and um obviously not having the right
situation to allow them to succeed it's
great to see you uh we're here at the
baseball stadium here I didn't know
which makes complete sense right we're
here at the Super Bowl and you guys go
to baseball stadium yeah well the
football field was taken now can you
name a football player that's played in
this Stadium
for the San Francisco Giants a football
player
this should be a layup by the way a
football player who played in this snow
no no one's there uh
uh let's think about anyone anyone
anyone
oh Seton
uh man I don't know why Russell Wilson
popped into my head but maybe he had
like Kyler Murray
well you okay how does I say from his
college days oh
you tell us Josh marja
[Music]
can you spell samarja
um
I think I was asked to do this in
college one time
so it's s-a-m
-a-r
this is where it gets tough so it's like
it's like
d-i-j-z-a or something like that
two F's
oh yeah yeah that's not g off it's Jeff
yeah right or you guys having a debate
about one or two F's on the Jeff here no
no no I'm not sure I don't know any
Jeff's with one f with a J is that a
thing no no it's just uh okay g-e-o-f-f
we don't like people all right we'll
take a break if you're watching on
peacock Brady is going to uh show us his
arm strength there oh I thought I was
doing that golf stuff well you can do
that too but you can we want to see if
you can throw it from right field to the
infield oh God okay can you do that I'll
try I might throw my arm out I haven't
thrown a ball and I don't know it's been
a while if there's a hospital right
across the street in case perfect you
know what you guys could take me in the
Sprinter van oh okay I like what some of
the Traeger the barbecue we're getting
uh and we're gonna go by the Charo Lodge
too while we're at it uh Brian
cranston's gonna join us top of the hour
we'll come back here on The Dan Patrick
Show after this